now at least eight people have died in  America's Midwest during one of the  worst freezes for many decades  temperatures have fallen below minus 30  Celsius in some places and heavy snow  and freezing winds are forecast to move  eastwards towards New York well it's all  caused by what's been known as a polar  vortex that's a circulation of  low-pressure and extremely cold air it  occurs over the Arctic now it forms  about 30 miles above the Earth's surface  typically it creates winds of more than  a hundred and 50 miles an hour as strong  as the most powerful of hurricanes but  if it becomes warmer than usual the air  can force the arctic air south over  North America and indeed parts of Europe  as well  that sends temperatures to under minus  20 degrees that's as cold as the South  Pole which is where the air comes from